What is your opinion of, and the person left this out, so I added this to the question, because the person asked the question, what is your opinion of for a person who has had estrogen driven breast cancer, the purpose taking it would be to help make muscle.
And so I added this, so if I don't think the person who asked the question is on the call.
But if you, if this is not what you meant, then please ask this question again for next week.
Because you didn't have the product in here. I assumed that you meant, because creatine is so commonly for the purpose of healthy make muscle.
So I just added it. So if this was your question, can a person with estrogen driven breast cancer take creatine, the answer is no.
So a creatine supplement, creatine supplementation is very, very popular in the exercise world.
Bodybuilders will be taking it because creatine can help build muscle, and it is proven to help build muscle. So people that want to build more muscle at our lifting weights typically will be taking creatine.
I wrote a blog post about this should cancer patients take creatine so you can learn about it right there.
And the answer is no, there was a study, a couple studies back in the 90s that said creatine can help people with cancer, but there's several dozen studies since then.
And the recent ones that actually say that creatine can increase the tasticis and increase the growth of a metastatic cancer.
So I just say no, and it's not just for breast cancer, it's for all sorts of cancer, but one of the studies specifically listed breast cancer with creatine.
So the simple answer to this should cancer patients take creatine, the answer is no.